can I even do that can I put Barry
inside teuvos mine not by yourself the
chair that I created so it contains an
imprint of clipit synaptic waves I will
use that to open a door and gear
subconscious then your ability to
telepathically inhabit others will serve
as a cerebral bridge allowing the
Flash's mind to connect the kibbutz I'm
guessing is really risky to put her into
the mind of a psychopath yeah
technically you would be connected
mentally to to vote so best-case I start
acting like him like I have been with
other people
worst case he uses his brain powers on
me and look we understand the risks if
you guys don't want to do this our baby
is not gonna live in a world without
love because of that madman if this is
what it takes to bring him down then I
say let's get it set up preferably
before my next contraction all right if
we're gonna do this we all have to agree
to it as a team
[Music]
hey you homeboy
now
problem
let's do it
everybody it's Charlie the flash season
4 is dropping on blu-ray next week so
the dropping deleted scenes but I also
have a clip of the actor that they just
cast to play rag doll from the comics
drink Season 5 so I'll play that in a
second then I'll talk about that then
I'll talk about season 4 deleted scenes
the extra cool thing on top of that is
that it also seemingly confirms that
they're gonna be doing the Icicle
character as Caitlin snows father so
I'll explain how that's connected to rag
doll but if you're new to the channel
there's a new round of that flash ring
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
the video I'll name a new winner at the
end of this here's a really creepy clip
of the actor that's playing rag doll
remember he's a contortionist from the
comics who's triple-jointed the reason
why rag doll is an important character
given what they just did with the
thinker during season 4 is that the
ragdoll character has history with the
thinker in the comics thinker
brainwashed rag doll to commit crimes
based on dolls he didn't really become
the crazy contortionist till much much
later in the comics it initially was
kind of silly
his son Peter mirco jr. is the rag doll
that ended up joining secrets 6 so he's
the more modern version of the character
that you think of when you think of rag
doll what they might be doing is just
combining both of those characters
because the old version of rag doll was
just a little bit silly the modern
version was a little more hardcore and I
think they're trying to go with a
slightly darker spin on season 5 the
episode he's gonna debut in is called
all dolled up it's episode 5 so
obviously that's a play on his comic
book origin where the thinker
brainwashed him to dress up and commit
crimes based on dolls but also a play on
the character ragdolls name the really
cool thing that's going on here because
we know that Caitlin's father is gonna
be a big thing in episode 6 the episode
right after ragdolls episode is the
Icicle cometh like they're literally
putting his name in the title as icicle
which is a play on the Iceman Cometh
which is a Broadway play making a kind
of sound like he's going to have some
sort of metahuman frost based powers in
the comics ragdolls arc actually led
into an injustice society arc with
icicle on the team so what I'm really
hoping that they do is that they pull
from that deep cut and Caitlin's father
winds up being icicle from the comics so
that he can be
villain because he was a member of the
injustice society pretty evil person but
not necessarily connected to Caitlin
snow in the comics so that would be the
TV show sort of changing their
backstories but I feel like that would
totally be fine if you're gonna do a
really interesting story for Caitlin it
makes sense if you're gonna connect
those characters because rag doll and
icicle were connected in the comics
here's a clip of that character just to
give you an idea what his abilities look
like and we better get to work
the other really cool easter-egg about
the Icicle character is is that remember
they're doing the Super Max movie for
the first half of arrow season Oliver
stuck in prison with all the criminals
that he put in there during the original
version of that movie that they were
gonna make a long time ago icicle was a
character in that so he actually has
ties to what they're doing on arrow
right now but it's not like he's gonna
show up during arrow season 7 is just an
easter egg for that original script it's
just nice to see those connections
behind the scenes it just all seems to
be pointing towards icicle happening
this season these actually might be the
younger versions of the Rogues that the
producers were talking about they says
they were introducing younger rogues
during Comic Cons you're like what does
that mean so we already know we have
spin we have rag doll hopefully
Caitlin's father is the Icicle character
and winds up being sort of a replacement
for the way the Captain Cold led the
original version of the Rogues the whole
thing about that though is is that while
the Rogues are still a very big villain
team in the flash TV show and in the
comics remember cicada wants to kill all
metahumans he wants to get rid of their
powers that's why we've been talking
about Cisco the death of vibe is also an
episode title so I think pretty much
everybody has kind of figured out now
that Cisco is probably just gonna lose
his abilities so he'll wind up being
Cisco in vibe the character the persona
that he has will end up dying and he
just won't be a metahuman anymore the
reason why they do things like that is
to balance the scales a little bit like
Cisco's ability is really powerful like
he can port them anywhere he can
actually stop people dead in their
tracks so I think they want to give him
an interesting character arc where he
has to rely more on his intellect and
less on his vibe abilities which I
actually think is better for the
character original Cisco worked really
well with the team even though he does
have really cool powers and they look
really cool on screen I haven't been
quite as big of a fan of the more recent
vibe stuff that they've done with the
character as I was with the original
version let me know in the comments
though because of all these icicle
Easter eggs that are happening in
episodes do you actually think that
they're doing that this season and
that's who caitlin Snow's father is
gonna turn into they're actually filming
episode 5 right now
so we actually might get a chance to see
what they're doing with Caitlin snows
father behind the scenes but they might
keep that green screen so if he actually
does turn into icicle we might not find
out about it for a while there's a whole
bunch more stuff coming up I'll try to
get through the videos as fast as
possible congratulations to the giveaway
winner from my last big video dan
mclellen please email me on the about
page of my channel so I can get your
contact details we actually don't know
if Nora's gonna be part of the crossover
right now so I can't say yes or no but I
will post an update if we find out more
about that click here to learn all about
them bringing Superman back and click
here for brand new spider-man far from
home thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]